we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail that came in recently
hey david just one less you know your
complete idiot from the best things
happen to this country in a long time
right and now you idiots just once shut
it down you're stupid you're stupid yeah
i don't really have to comment on this
one but i would be interested to know
what specific policy achievements has
donald trump passed that the caller
thinks is evidence that Donald Trump is
doing more good for us than anyone in
recent history I don't remember the
exact language that he used I'd be
interested to hear what policies Trump
is executed that you really liked on the
bonus show today comedian louis c.k
admits to sexual misconduct and a number
of media companies are cutting ties with
him as well a new study suggests that
women are less likely to receive CPR
from bystanders very interesting data
and also a woman climbs through a
drive-through window at mcdonald's and
assaults the McDonald's worker over none
other than Chicken McNuggets you know if
it was one of those shakes I could
understand jumping through a window and
ringing someone's neck at McDonald's but
the chicken nuggets are quite frankly
not that good so that that's a weird
story that we're gonna delve into on
today's bonus show how do you access the
bonus show well there's two ways number
one you get a membership at david
pakman.com slash membership if you want
a discount the coupon code is I voted 17
second option for membership is
contribute at the $5 a month level at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
nearly 2100 of you have now contributed
on patreon and for every two patreon
contributors I will remove one piece
from the Jenga tower and as you can see
and Pat looks very scared every time I
gesture near it because it is on its
last leg we have made 26 moves here from
52 different patrons meaning that if the
tower were to fall before I'm able to
make another move that will trigger a 56
52 percent discount code off of
membership 26 pieces
means 52% off if I can move a few more
pieces tomorrow or the next day the
discount will be approaching 60% which
is stunning Pat we'll pick up a couple
hundred thousand memberships if we do
that so very very exciting patreon.com
slash david packard show david
pakman.com slash membership I will speak
to you briefly momentarily I mean on the
bonus show